tout le monde se demande un truc qui des
tuyaux qui sortaient de partout j'étais
des visages et le médecin dit non ça
c'est pas moi c'est pas possible un
moment de ma vie donc où je jugeais une
différence une grosse différence en
plein visage ça a été difficile je
sortais plus je faisais pas d'amis même
sur mon téléphone je parlais à presque
personne que la famille mais maintenant
j'ai plus d'assurance j'ai compris c'est
quoi la vie et je me suis laissé aller
je sors je vis ma vie il a personne à
qui ça ne plaît pas c'est pas mon
problème
[Musique]
petit bout je mets tout en le regardant
on est en train de faire un shooting en
pleine forêt en pleine nature
c'est ce que je préfère le mieux c'est
vrai j'ai une différence sur physique
sur le visage mais la vie ne s'arrête
pas là je vais pas enterrer mes rêves
parce que j'ai une différence
physiquement et comme je dis toujours la
chance ne mérite pas la chance arrache
dormoy aujourd'hui j'arrache ma chance
et j'ai deviné rêve malgré mon physique
mon rêve c'est d'aller le plus loin
possible le brier le maximum possible
pas brillant pour briller mais briller
pour apporter de la lumière dans la vie
des gens comme moi les gens qui ont une
différence briller pour partager ce
bonheur tout est différent la société ce
bonheur d'accepter la personne connaît
dorénavant
moi
[Musique]
l'avocat ce ne va jamais effacer la
cicatrice la prothèse c'est juste pour
le contact avec l'extérieur
du coup souvent cette question de savoir
quand j'aurai l'âge très très très très
avancés avec plein de rires et où est ce
que j'aurai toujours la faute et à cet
âge les midis je ne sais pas si c'est
possible de faire une prothèse plein
goerig pourquoi pas mais sinon je pense
que d'ici à là je me serais un adapté à
un co prothèses ou pas de côté donc peu
importe même pas 2 mais la porte est
vraiment c'est quelque chose de très
important c'est quelque chose de très
constructif pour des personnes comme moi
ça m'a construit sa marque complètement
construite ça m'a complètement donné la
force dont j'avais besoin pour me
relever est aujourd'hui si je peux
sortir dans la rue sans ma protestent
c'est pas parce que je géante rouge et
peur où je me prouver quoi que ce soit
aux gens non c'est juste parce que grâce
à cette prothèse je me suis acceptée
déjà naturellement je me suis acceptée
avec la prothèse